GAUTAMI NADKARNI: Hey, Lorin.
Let's go.
I thought we were going
to go out for ice cream.
LORIN PRICE: Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to cleanse
my data, and it's taking
so much longer than I thought.
And I'm trying to learn Python,
and it's just not going well.
GAUTAMI NADKARNI: Well, why?
Google has a managed service
for this called Dataprep.
Let me show you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's get right into
the Dataprep tool.
If you're using the
Dataprep for the first time,
accept approvals and give it
couple of seconds to load.
We can start by creating a flow.
Give it a name and
description, and click Create.
You have the option
of importing data
either from your local
machine, Google Cloud
Storage, or BigQuery.
For this demo, we are going
to use Cloud Storage bucket.
I have preloaded a few
ice cream sales data sets
into Cloud Storage.
This is the data set I will
use for the Dataprep flow.
Click on the data set you want
to begin the transformation
with and click on Edit Recipe.
A recipe contains
a sequence of steps
that transforms the selected
data set into a new data set.
The Wrangle language is
used to create recipes.
LORIN PRICE: Uh-oh.
Wrangle language?
Am I still going to have to
learn another programming
language?
GAUTAMI NADKARNI: Actually, no.
Wrangle language is
a lot like formulas
you see in Google Sheets.
And you don't have to
write it on your own.
A lot of it is
auto-generated for you.
LORIN PRICE: Phew.
OK, good.
Let's keep going.
GAUTAMI NADKARNI:
For this demo, we
will build tasks
performed by data analysts
regularly like cleansing,
structuring, and enriching.
As you can see, this
is the basic view
of how data looks across
different columns and rows.
After looking at data, you
might see some mismatched values
in red for one of the columns.
Upon clicking it, you might
realize that something
was wrong with the data--
in this case, the at
symbol in the number field.
The tool also gives you
some auto suggestions
for this column to choose from.
I'm going to fix this column
by using a value given to me
by the business analyst for
a typical serial number.
Split by delimiter
allows you to separate
values in the same column by
a delimiter-- in this case,
the forward slash.
I'm going to rename
these columns now
for better understanding.
We can also easily join multiple
data sets in just a few clicks.
Let's join two
data sets with one
of the existing data set that
we have loaded in the flow.
Type ID is automatically
detected as the join key,
and you can choose
which column you
want to display
for both the data
sets post the join function.
To hide a column, simply
right click on the column
and hide it.
Similarly, I'm
going to be joining
one more data set using flavor
ID to further enrich my data.
Changing data types is
super simple as well.
Let's remove the percentage
symbol from the profit margin
percentage column and convert
it into [? integer ?] data type.
Lastly, let's apply
some custom logic
to create a new data column.
The CASE function
allows you to perform
multiple conditional tests
on a set of expressions
with a statement.
Here, I'm going to define a
range of profits and demands
from low, medium, and high based
on the ranges of the value they
might fall in.
After these steps, my
pipeline is now ready to run.
I'll select a couple
options for how
I want my results to be stored.
I can also choose if I want
the job to run manually
or scheduled.
And voila, we can run the job.
LORIN PRICE: Wow, this
is really cool, and easy.
Once I create the recipes,
I can run the jobs anytime.
And I don't even
need to learn Python.
GAUTAMI NADKARNI: Absolutely.
Can we now eat our ice creams?
LORIN PRICE: Don't forget to
subscribe for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
GAUTAMI NADKARNI:
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]